[Music]
[Applause]
Tom Silverstone he covers the Packers
beat reporter for the Milwaukee Journal
Sentinel house morale in Green Bay
uh that's a good question
um I you know I mean I think people are
just glad it's over I I think we
everybody knew it was going to happen
and I don't think anybody didn't think
it was going to happen before the draft
and we're all just sitting here
twiddling our thumbs waiting to see you
know what the final result was going to
be and finally we got it
Lakers did pretty well getting what they
got for a guy that they didn't want
anymore
I mean I asked around the league I have
you know some people Personnel people
from other teams and I just kind of
surveyed them and you know some said
this is about what they predicted it
would be and others said they thought
the Packers fleeced the Jets
you know I'm probably somewhere in
between that I think the Packers the big
thing is that the Packers got
a good pick next year and it is sort of
a a loss for the Jets if Rogers is one
and done Rogers plays two years then
it's a pretty good deal for them and I'm
guessing if he does play two years well
plays this year in more than 65 snaps
you're going to get the Jets first round
pick next year it gets upgraded from a
second to a first that that would be
later in the first round so it's not
going to be you know a top 15 pick
correct it's not and you know the only
way that it could be decent as if you
know history repeats itself which it
seems to uh uh at every turn and that's
that you know Rogers plays and then
hertz's biceps tears his biceps so I far
a bit and and then you know he he plays
the 65 and then he's done so I who knows
how it'll play out
um but you're you're right I don't I
think it's going to be at best a middle
round pick and more than likely a late
pick all right Jordan love come on down
front and center here
what do we know about him given that
he's started one game
not a whole heck of a lot I mean I've
had the chance you know a beat guy I've
had the chance to watch
human practice and training camp mostly
uh from the minute he got there to where
he is now and he has made tremendous
progress I mean maybe that's more of a
reflection on how bad he was early on I
mean I I think is a relative term but I
think he was just inexperienced and they
had to remold him into a pro quarterback
after what he had done at Utah State so
I I think he's got all the tools it's
just you know that you need tools and
then you got to perform and that's what
we're gonna find out how does this go
wrong
um
if he's a total bust I mean if he's a
bust
you know then
you know they're gonna they're gonna
give him the fifth year option he's
gonna make 20 million next year he's on
the roster
so if if he's a boss they don't have a
future I don't think they're going to
draft anybody in the first round and I
don't think anybody in the fourth or
fifth round is going to wind up being a
savior so that's that's where it goes
then they're starting all over from
scratch
what do the Packers do with that 13th
pick overall Thursday yeah that's a good
question I know everybody wants them to
draft a wide receiver and I'm like stop
it stop it they don't take wide
receivers in the first round how about a
tight end
yeah and
I think I mean if I were them I would
take an offensive tackle their their
left tackle is
um you know on his last legs he's still
a good player but
um you know they've gotta gotta get
ready for the future but on the other
hand I was also thinking you know the
Patriots and the Jets behind them need
offensive tackles someone may want to
jump up to 13 and uh try to get a tackle
so move back you know move back and then
take a tight end at the end of the round
and keep accumulating picks I I think
that's how you build around Jordan love
are you gonna miss the drama
oh you know what I was thinking about
this Dan I'm like this is probably the
last time we're ever gonna talk
when Jordan love finishes his Hall of
Fame career so well if the Packers
aren't any good I'll call you Tom
and if they're really good I'll call you
I I don't know what I did wrong in my
life yeah Barb and Rogers
but you survived you survived both of
them I did I did but I guarantee you I
will not be around for the end of Jordan
love if he's a Hall of Fame quarterback
at their best
who was better farv or Rogers
um
I've always I've always sided with farf
because if there was a guy I wanted
in the fourth quarter of any game
to win it he was going to be it I mean I
I I think I would take him in in a New
York minute because of that and you know
Rogers is the most efficient maybe more
talented than far but you know when I
want to win a game I want somebody who's
not afraid you know who's daring and
that's what I thought farv was and I
thought he won with less I mean a lot of
people think Rogers didn't have the
tools but far I've had less than Rogers
did much less I don't know if you needed
to say New York minute there it's
interesting
yeah
Tom thanks for joining us we appreciate
it okay it's my pleasure always Tom
Silverstone he covers the Packers for
the Milwaukee Milwaukee Journal Center